all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with Defenders
Beyond and we are here with two of the
most powerful beings that you've never
heard of one of whom is a cosmic entity
so what this does here picking up off
the heels of the last video is it
initially picks up with Adam Brashear
the blue Marvel right and so this guy
actually saves President Kennedy from
being taken out by Lee Harvey Oswald now
of course he appears to President
Kennedy and is just kind of like imagine
what would have happened if I'd have
learned about this on TV and he even
goes as far as to tell him like you
better have your concession speech ready
Mr Kennedy because the next time you
hear from me it's going to be in the
primaries and then following that it
picks up really in kind of the present
day after blue Marvel has won the
presidency and of course retired the
presidency was decades ago and then in
turn it's just kind of celebrating with
all the different members of The
Avengers and you'll notice the Avengers
look different than they normally do
Spider-Man is still wearing the suit
that he got in secret Wars the beyonder
is currently around which he's not
technically part of the Avengers you're
seeing a team and a group of people that
don't necessarily exist in their current
form Tigra for whatever reason that
makes sense to nobody but Al Ewing is
basically the leader of the Avengers and
has the power to lift Thor's hammer it's
one of these funny things because what
you're seeing here is an alteration of
reality as most of you guys know from
reading the history of Adam Brashear in
Marvel Comics he was asked to step down
by President Kennedy and where this
story really seems to maintain that
conversation between the two unlike what
we saw in the main Marvel Universe with
Adam Brashear in this reality he chose
not to step down and in fact he ignored
President Kennedy's order and continued
operating as a superhero and was then
successfully elected to the presidency
of the United States and from there you
pick up with America Chavez who has her
sister in tow and has also met with her
mothers in the utopian parallel the real
utopian parallel right so her mothers
are alive beyond that you have the
arrival of Taya the mother of galatus
and when she gets there of course
Galactus is in toe which gives us the
return of Life bringer Galactus now
we're going to make sense of all this
here in a second because it's important
that you understand what's going on here
beyond the different alterations of
reality involving like the Avengers and
so on and so forth this ties into the
work that Al Ewing's done already so for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with Taya and are unfamiliar with the
lifebringer Taya was introduced in the
main Defender story that was written by
Al Ewing technically Defenders Beyond is
kind of a spin-off slash sort of ending
of the defender's story as Al Ewing had
done it but tire was brought in when you
basically had the Defenders who had
transitioned to the previous reality
before the current one and they
discovered the parents of Galactus now
it was kind of alewing reworking
everything sort of adjusting everything
to sort of fit his needs but the thing
about this is that lifebringer Galactus
originated in Al Ewing's ultimates run
that in all new all different Marvel
when the ultimates were launched which
was honestly if I'm being quite Frank
with you guys the ultimates comic book
was the best comic that no one was
reading right that thing was is the best
thing going in all new Alder from Marvel
and I don't care what anybody says it
was a ridiculously phenomenal story
check this out the team was nuts you had
the blue Marvel who led the team you had
black panther America Chavez Captain
Marvel Monica Rambo and then eventually
you had Auntie man Connor since it was
nuts like it was so powerful the first
thing they did was fight and overpower
Galactus and then continue his Evolution
right the the situation that alewing
presented was that when Galactus emerged
and started consuming worlds that he
hadn't fully evolved what the ultimates
did is they evolved him to his final
form which was the lifebringer so he
literally started traveling around the
universe bringing back all the worlds
that he had previously consumed it was
pretty awesome the crazy thing about
this is that we get this kind of
monologue coming from America Chavez
where she says that for a moment all of
this just feels Perfect all of us
together in celebration in an ideal
world there's not even any villains
which really begs the question why do
the Avengers even it exists in the first
place right that this whole thing is
perfect and that it's too perfect she
realizes there's something on her face
that she's wearing the eternity mask and
that's when she breaks free of this
false reality and we realize that none
of what she's seeing is actually real
now of course glorion is the one behind
all of this and he even goes so far is
to alter reality and to say okay fine if
what you want is the real Galactus then
here's the real Galactus and he shows
her just like this monstrosity Galactus
like as we know him right the Devourer
of Worlds and it's kind of nuts because
you have him really talking to America
Chavez and coming to this realization
The Eternity mask even outside all
universes some things are Universal and
it makes you the equal of anyone you
fight so it gives you the power to break
free of my illusory worlds but why would
you want to fight me look what it's
doing to all of the others and so he
goes as far as to tell America Chavez
look at Taya finally confronting the
knowledge of what her little gallon
would become when that universe that
they're in eyes and he's born into the
new universe I could give her false hope
again if you ask and when America Chavez
asks what is this place his response is
I told you you're in the abyss the land
of couldn't be shouldn't be the furthest
place from reality there is nothing
happens here there are no stories and
it's one of those things because what
Marvel really gives us and what Al
Ewing's been doing kind of consolidating
really everything he's done in Marvel
Comics so far especially considering
what we have here is that as we
mentioned in the last video you have a
universe right the main Marvel Universe
if we want to call it that beyond the
main Marvel Universe you have the
Multiverse beyond the Multiverse you
have the Beyond realm where the
beyonders reside beyond that you have
the white hot room where the white
Phoenix of the crown resides and then
beyond that you have this the land of
couldn't be shouldn't be now the funny
thing about this is that Al Ewing didn't
invent any of these outside of like the
far Shore which is basically where
Cosmic entities go to die and by all
standards the measurement is the realm
of the one one above all and I don't
necessarily know how you reconcile that
place with this place the important
thing here is that in these locations
right in these Realms it was all
invented before him the land of couldn't
be shouldn't be as far as I'm aware that
was invented by Dan slot in a Silver
Surfer run now the thing about the land
of couldn't be shouldn't be is that this
is the place where basically only ideas
reside things that have never really
come to fruition right so if the
possibility exists out there this is
where that possibility resides before it
becomes real it's a very meta textual
realm but again glorion is the one that
rules in this realm seemingly at this
place now the reason why I say this guy
is so astronomically powerful is because
what this guy does is remove a piece of
himself and create a whole entire
Multiverse out of it like a Multiverse
of possibilities because as he's talking
to America Chavez he says you're the one
that's breaking things around here
America Chavez what I want is to make
these things true before I died before I
was trapped here I had the chance tends
to become the living personification of
the Multiverse and my eighth Cosmos
would not have been a mere continuation
it would have been a cosmic reboot a new
beginning for everyone what he's
referring to is basically the universe
as it exists now after the events of
Secret Wars 2015. remember Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers The New Avengers run
basically detailed the idea of the
beyonders intending to wipe out the
entirety of the Multiverse had they been
successful the Multiverse would have
restarted because it's the natural order
of things but what glorian is saying
here is that in his mind what he would
have done after becoming the embodiment
of all things in existence the entirety
of the Multiverse he would have rebooted
in some ways I have to believe this is
Al Ewing basically saying if I were the
one running the show I would have
rebooted the entire landscape of Marvel
Comics he says look America Chavez look
at what the Dead Land could be and
that's when it kind of astonishes her
because she's like you're using your own
substance to make an entire Multiverse
and he says for now but if you choose
this paradise that I've made for you
give it something of yours we can keep
it going together I.E if you believe in
this and if you choose to become a part
of this reality you will now exist in an
alternate reality you'll exist in an
alternate universe because you believing
in it has given it form it's one of
those really really cool but meta
textual things and in fact lorian says
like look at what I've done for all of
you right Adam Brashear has the answer
to the one question that torments him
what might have been Taya gets to be
proud of her son Tigres an a-lister with
the respect of her peers which is kind
of funny because the reality is she's
not an a-lister and no one cares about
Tigra
and he says even the beyonder is finally
content in this world surrounded by
people who basically adore him and it's
just one of those things where it's like
you America Chavez you could have
everything that you ever wanted you
could have your sister your moms are
alive the utopian parallel is a place
that you can go to you can have a home
he says you can have the life that
you've always wanted don't you feel like
you deserve it and her response isn't
necessarily no to the question of does
she deserve it it's no to do I want to
live in this world and she's like I'll
stick with what I've got now that's
what's so interesting about all this is
because the reality is that for us as
people right for you me anybody else our
life is in some ways kind of governed
and admired by the question what if I
had done this differently right like
what if I had taken a hundred dollars
and invested it in Bitcoin when it was
trading at a fraction of a penny I'd be
I'd be a billionaire right now I'd be
astronomically Rich well maybe not maybe
not with 100 bucks but like you'd have a
lot more money than you have right now
right like what if I had made this
decision regarding college instead of
that decision what if I gone to a trade
school instead of college right what if
I had done this or that or any number of
things I think for us as people it's
natural to look at the decisions that
we've made over the course of our lives
and to wonder what if we had done
something different this conversation
between Gloria and America Chavez and
even the other members of The Defenders
who jump in Tai is showing up and saying
this is the kingdom of never the true
world of couldn't be shouldn't be if
gallon plays big hungry in the cosmos to
come he has a key role in future history
that's the role that he's supposed to
play to fix him up quote unquote would
be to wipe him out and when glorian's
saying things like I would do a reboot
after reboot right I would just reboot
over and over and over again until I got
quote unquote the perfect Universe until
I got it right the response to Taya is
like is that really what it's going to
be us as individuals here or just play
things for you to just kind of rewrite
reality on your whim until you figure
out what it is even blue Marvel says I'd
rather live my own life whether I made
the right choices or not then some cozy
historical fiction this is them sort of
looking at glorion and saying like yes
we could kind of have this perfect world
as you created and yes our lives would
be would be rebooted over and over again
but the truth is we are the people that
we are because of the choices that we
made and so it's really kind of
intriguing here because when you have
glory and he says okay fine like nobody
else is going to side with me right find
whatever you guys are going to reject
all this that's cool with the power of
the Beyond or I can draw on that and
everything will be cool if I can get to
be honor to agree with this I can draw
on the beyonder's power and do seemingly
anything that I want to and the funny
thing about to be honor is true you
could I do have unlimited power I could
do virtually anything that I want to I'm
one of the most powerful beings in
existence but the reality is my only
real desire is to understand desire and
seeing the Defenders resist your offers
well that was just simply fascinating
and it makes me want to hear from all
five of them not the four that you've
set free and so he ultimately unleashes
Loki and then brings Loki in now the
funny thing about this is remember Loki
as he exists now is the god of stories
and they're in the land of couldn't be
shouldn't be which means if it's
basically like writing on an empty page
whatever Loki puts there becomes an
absolute truth that's the way this works
his power literally runs the opposite of
glorian's power glorion is imbued by all
the possibilities that can exist but
he's limited to whatever Loki does right
and so literally at that point going
forward Loki gets the eternity mask
right it's literally handed to him by
America Chavez that makes him equal to
glorion at that point he just starts
writing the narrative he's just like
okay cool like let's see what we can do
Loki holding this mask he literally says
oh I get it the mask is a piece of
Eternity substance with a handful of
this glorion really could have made his
dream world real infected eternity from
the inside but unlike certain moldy
golden oldies I think outside the box
and so where he's begged by glorion the
response of Loki is see what I mean DOL
DOL DOL you've got nothing I want
glorian not even a fight being equal to
you is a step down with me wielding this
eternity mask but what else can I use a
little piece of Eternity for maybe to
contact other Cosmic entities who is a
multiversal personification that I've
got on speed dial and this is when he
draws the queen of Nevers now the queen
of Nevers is a ridiculously powerful
Cosmic entity and depending on on who's
writing the story and how you handle it
her power could transcend that of the
Living Tribunal she'd be second to the
one above all and the reason why is
because she represents the sum total of
any and all possibilities the
possibility of the Living Tribunal being
destroyed and never returning the
possibility of the one above all dying
she represents all these different
things and so as a result of that her
power is a reflection of that now again
it's one of these things Works fast and
loose some of you guys may kind of draw
the conclusion well in that case she's
more powerful than the one above all I
mean no like Marvel does create a
definitive hierarchy the one above all
is called the one above all for a reason
but she says I'm called the queen of
Nevers who is also queen of always that
is one of those things where it's like
anything that is possible I represent I
represent all these different things and
so literally she whisks The Defenders
away from glorion and brings them
directly to her realm and so that's
where she says that much like eternity
and infinity she exists as a sort of
balance here right that where eternity
represents time and infinity represents
space that the queen of Nevers one part
of her does represent couldn't be
shouldn't be things that should never
happen things that should never take
place and things that can never take
place because they shouldn't take place
but she also represents can be shall be
which means things that can take place
therefore there are things that will
take place right basically the idea is
that Marvel Comics writers have their
mom was approved of I mean if we're
being honest here and we're using meta
textual stuff this Marvel editorial
saying you know what we'll go ahead and
go with that idea that idea resides in
the land of Canby shaldi the idea is
where Marvel's just like no we're never
gonna do that that resides in the land
of couldn't be be right if we're using
Comics as a meta textual kind of
representation of how Marvel does things
that's really how this stuff works but
again what we have here is her talking
about this notion of unchecked
possibility right that unchecked
possibility is definitively freedom even
in your world you'd be surprised at what
can actually happen again it's sort of
this alluing commentary on the fact that
this idea of thinking that your life is
somehow limited right like you have to
work a nine to five because that's the
only way to find success and it's the
only way to retire right that that's
limited thinking I make a living
rambling about comic books for 30
minutes right like don't talk to me
about what can or cannot be done your
ability to achieve things in your life
or in this life especially in this
digital age when everything is
accessible at your fingertips it's
limited only by your imagination right
it's one thing that I would love for you
guys to take away from this is that at
the end of the day your ability to live
your life and the things that you can
achieve in your life is limited by your
imagination the important thing here is
this right that in this conversation
that takes place between like the
Defenders and so on Loki says but how
come you're here instead of back there
in the world that we came from not to be
a downer but I've experienced what's
quote unquote possible there and it
absolutely hurt because Loki was turned
into a tree but she says I'm on my
journey you're on yours and none of us
have the map but she says I can promise
you one thing my cynical Storyteller the
journey never ends not even when we pass
through the final door Defenders the
door to the godhood itself and what she
does is she presents them to the door of
God and says this door here it leads to
the house of ideas now where that leads
to we'll find out in the next video but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching hopefully I was able to inspire
you I apologize for my little soapbox
rants but I will catch you all later
peace